turistas de francia y del resto de
europa han estado llegando al aeropuerto
de madrid- por centenares a diferencia
de francia los bares y restaurantes
están abiertos en la capital española
ofreciendo una capacidad limitada en sus
interiores y sin límite de capacidad al
aire libre donde se permite que grupos
de hasta 6 personas se sientan alrededor
de una sola mesa en madrid el 'toque de
queda' empieza a las 11 de la noche a
diferencia de francia donde comienza a
las 7 una estela salimos de francia para
venir a madrid y es increíble es incluso
un poco surrealista estar bebiendo una
cerveza fuera de un bar cuando país está
cerrado es mágico se mastica sentimos
que somos libres de hacer lo que
queramos es un verdadero placer va a ser
genial sin embargo la llegada de
turistas a madrid presenta una paradoja
mientras los residentes de la capital se
les tiene prohibido salir de la ciudad
muchos se preguntan por qué se permite
que las personas vengan del extranjero
es una decisión muy rara y muy difícil
de entender no veo bien que un
extranjero venga
que puede tener el convidado igual que
lo puedo tener yo entonces creo que no
se está llevando las medidas para todo
el mundo la comisión europea ha
condenado la política de puertas
abiertas de madrid y pide una mejor
cuestión sobre el kobe 19 entre los
estados miembros de la unión europea